hey how are you thank you for taking the
time to chat with us i love i loved this
season first and foremost it was really
scary i was very terrifying so from a
sale 1 to 10 how would you say how scary
it was
to film or like to watch
both
um i would say
like when we were filming uh we we had
actually like a lot more fun than it
looks like we did um
and to watch i mean it is pretty scary
it's like uh out of ten i mean
i don't know it's a pretty
if you don't like horror it's it's up
there it's like not you know eight nine
ten kind of thing
yeah so talk about behind the scenes any
fun moments that you want to share with
us
definitely yeah um i got to spend i mean
you know i got to spend some time in
atlanta a little bit where we usually
shoot um to shoot some scenes for the
first episode and then the rest of the
series or season i shot in um
albuquerque new mexico and um
that was just incredible because like we
just had a great crew and uh
we
got to just like really bond with each
other because a lot of the time we were
kind of in the middle of nowhere in the
desert and like it was just me and the
cast and me and charlie heaton and
eduardo franco and noah schnapp and
millie and
um we all just
we all really bonded and um
you know usually
we're all in atlanta and like uh you
know we see each other every day and
it's like this like thing we're like
yeah i'll see you tomorrow like this is
like we like in a good way we're like
forced to like hang out and and like
yeah
in a really awesome way you know that's
great so talking about you and millie
your relationship goes through 11's
going through it you guys are navigating
long distance
what would you say how that affected
your characters and affected your
relationship
um
i think
it definitely has affected our
relationship i think like there's a lot
of things that i think they both have to
learn about themselves this season 11
mike and um
you know uh about yeah about themselves
in order to like
especially for mike in order to like
have you know proper um
you know the love that 11 wants him to
give and and for all of his
relationships and um in general so
yeah i think it's kind of a
as well a coming-of-age story within
this kind of crazy horror
thing
yeah so we see the cast very much
maturing and you guys are tackling
another terrifying monster high school
so how is navigating that part of your
character
um
yeah i think he's mike is just trying to
find his way and trying to find his own
kind of friend group and he finally
settles and
finds a group that he really identifies
with and that's taken a while and um
yeah i think he's um
he's happy that he has people that kind
of call his own
yeah definitely i also since we know
stranger things is ending season five
there's been lots of talks about
spin-offs so if you were to pitch a
spin-off what would you want to do
yeah it's a good question um i'm not
sure you know i i i think the world of
stranger things is so
uh
vast and big um like the mythology and
um you can kind of get away with a lot
because there's so many alternate kind
of
you know the the the upside down being
kind of an alternate dimension and um
the back story i mean i i don't know if
i'd ever do uh
you know maybe in like a 10 15 years or
something if netflix wants to have us
all back and do like a sequel or
whatever that would be great
yeah as far as as far as spin-offs go
i'm not really sure i think like after
five i think the whole point of season
five is for
the hawkins kind of our story to kind of
take its
uh you know final whatever bow and um
end in the prop and in a proper way so
um
yeah i'm not sure maybe you would go
somewhere else then poison hawkins i
loved watching the season i was very
terrified i thought psychologically and
lots of horror elements i just want to
say thank you so much and for all of it
it was such a great season i know the
fans will love it
thank you so much i'm so nice